[Applause]
[Music]
we're back from e3 how about all those
big games and trailers huh I totally
didn't record this ahead of time and hey
if you want to make sure you get the
latest episodes of new releases
delivered right to you be sure to hit
that subscribe button now before we dive
into this week let's see what released
during the show arms is like we boxing
on steroids
if steroids turned you into mr.
fantastic super spreads mr. fantastic
can stretch up to three times his size
in case it wasn't immediately obvious
arms doesn't play like your standard
fighter instead you move around the
arena and fling a variety of punches and
ranged attacks at your opponent every
character has their own perks like being
able to heal or warp through the air
combine that with all the different arm
attachments and you've got yourself
plenty of options for throwing down you
can duel one-on-one play two versus two
or take the competition online arms is
out right now on Nintendo switch but if
you're not sure about taking a swing at
it you can always check out game spots
video review now on to the games that
haven't come out yet the next chapter of
Final Fantasy 14 is storm blood and this
expansion takes place in the lands of
amigo and DOMA it includes all the good
stuff you'd expect new Red Mage and
samurai job classes and increased level
cap new dungeons and raids and plenty of
new gear and that's just the short list
combat and job classes have also been
smoothed out with increased inventory
space for all players if you're ready
for a new adventure Final Fantasy 14
storm blood launches on ps4 and PC on
Tuesday June 20th if you're more into
tactics than MMOs God Wars Future Passed
could be right up your alley
the turn-based battles include 30
different classes 200 weapons and more
than 600 different skills for your units
to learn so that's like I don't even
know how many different combos you can
use against soldiers and bosses the
story is based on Japanese folklore with
characters and events
happening all across Japan if you're
ready to dive into the isometric world
of God wars you can do it on ps4 and
Vita on June 20th let's move from feudal
Japan to the mech Wars of next machina
this is the next game from the team that
brought you detonation and resogun so
you should know what to expect a
top-down twin-stick shooter with way too
many evil robots that need blowing up
there are plenty of power-ups and weapon
boosters to grab along the way but it's
more than just robots you'll need to
overcome next machina includes several
different leaderboards letting you
compete for high scores among your
friends and your city or country and
across the whole world
you can fire off all those lasers and
bullets on ps4 and PC on the 20th and if
robot wards are too violent for you why
not check out the cutesy ever Oasis it's
been described as Animal Crossing plus
an RPG and that's pretty fair you play
as tesu a young villager who must
rebuild the Oasis by venturing out into
the desert completing quests for
villagers lets you swap them in to the
party for future quests and the more
materials you find out in the wild the
more you can grow your town with shops
and other buildings tattoos journey is
perfect for playing on the go because
it's coming to 3ds on Friday the 23rd
and those are the big games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
except for the stuff that's already out
of course thanks for watching guys and
I'll be back with your regularly
scheduled new releases next week